welcome to Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon the
franchise that pioneered the tactical
genre in 2001 Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
defines the squad based military shooter
genre with realistic and challenging
gameplay
as a powerful sequel Ghost Recon 2
introduces a dynamic shift to
third-person and supports up to 16
players and enhanced multiplayer modes
Ghost Recon Advanced Warfighter improves
the focus on team coordination and
features actual military prototype
equipment and weapons
one year later Ghost Recon Advanced
Warfighter - delivers a deeply immersive
campaign and multiplayer future war
experience with the ability to command
supporting units
in 2012 Ghost Recon Future Soldier makes
a shift to exhilarating cover based
gameplay with the inclusion of the stink
shot gunsmith an adaptive camouflage
technology
and in 2017 Ghost Recon wildlands leads
a tactical shooter into a breathtaking
open world experience to explore either
solo or up to four player co-op as well
as an attack table for D for PvP mode in
ghost war
and now the future of Ghost Recon hey
everyone
my name is Emil Dallben I'm the US army
green beret I've served with Special
Forces for 14 years and have deployed
all over the world I'm also very proud
to be a writer on a new Ghost Recon game
being part of the Ubisoft team has been
an incredible journey for me and we are
so excited to share with you our
community an experience that is going to
bring players closer to real Special
Operations missions than ever before
when we launched Ghost Recon violence we
released an action-packed of a world
military shooter that can be played in
solo and a four player co-op from
beginning to end will completely blown
away by your response we are so grateful
to a community that has brought to more
than 50 million players it's an honor
the stakes are high today we're super
excited to introduce a brand new goal
second game to you so let's get to it
our story begins on a remote island in
the middle of the Pacific Ocean called
Aurora
the mythical golem was imagined as an
artificial intelligence designed to
serve and protect the myth is now a
reality
this self-driving vehicle crossed the
entire United States without a human
touching the wheel
the computer was creative it outsmarted
me every step of the way
entrepreneur visionary genius JCL is
planning to change the world
this is our first deployment of lethal
drones they have already saved countless
US lives from our new headquarters on
Nauru archipelago Skell technology will
quite simply build the future
skel type drones will enhance industries
across the globe they will eliminate
food shortages heal the sick and in time
erase poverty mr. Skell critics claim
but with new autonomous systems we risk
summoning the devil what do you say to
that we combine AI machinery to serve
humanity peacefully
I am personally dedicated
scary machines that can act together
react faster than humans they're cheaper
more efficient than any other measure
there's no doubt that swarm surveillance
systems will reduce crime on our streets
with mr. Skell care to comment on the
recent assassination of a political
candidate by a lethal drone mr. Skell
has no comment at this time
lethal autonomous weapons are being
developed and deployed without oversight
or limitations they are the next global
threat the UN must vote to enact
sanctions on the spread of these weapons
we must act now
we've lost contact with her Ella no way
to reach Jake's Kell yes sir I
understand the risk level we're sending
them in
the ghouls are elites pickup soldiers
the best of the best the just how far
can you push the ghouls
how strong are they how much then detect
before the break a breakpoint is a force
posture change shift from attacked fan
from defend to withdraw recon to survive
it is the moment when a unit is lost its
combat effectiveness is no longer able
to find the onset of this inability to
carry out a mission constitutes a breath
boy
this is Ghost Recon break point in the
past the ghost had a plan what if this
time there was no briefing what is this
time the enemy expected let's start at
the beginning of course recon break
points your callsign is no mad because
sent 200 odd you have been sent there
for what seems to be a usual mission but
this is far from what is about to happen
from this point on all of your military
survival skills will be put to the test
as you make your way through this
mysterious island you will discover the
majesty the beauty and diversity of this
brand new open world from snowy peaks to
sandy beaches jungles deserts fjords
even a volcano but you're not on a road
to sightsee nestled in a beautiful
archipelago and driven by the singular
vision of accomplished engineer JCL they
develop AI and autonomous drones scarce
mission is to make the world a better
place
but the road to hell is paved with good
intentions in the wrong hands Aurora
could turn into the most dangerous place
on earth and it does you are no longer
the hunter you are the hunter and even
worse the hunters are unit of Elliot's
pickup soldiers gone rogue he had the
same training as you the same experience
and they could then say of the wolves
and they have taken over the island the
wolves are the most formidable opponents
the ghosts have ever had to face not
only have they taken over a role they've
also reprogrammed skells drones to
become powerful killing machines
you lost behind enemy lines
and your enemy is powerful and nurses so
ghosts can you survive your breakpoint
ghost one one this ghost now I'm true
Mike set your location but a guy some
pads on my ass value me to eliminate the
threat
[Music]
[Music]
good
nothing to report I'm gonna continue my
search
reporting for the patient you have lost
out there right
[Music]
you ready good
[Music]
picked over
Bravo Team will send a diversion of the
gate me and one one will it fill the
campers rare
I got right
groans OH
there are no walls but they got numbers
Bravo Team your position
three hostiles that's an office draw
there's nothing here either nothing ever
happens around here
I have the drones out
go sleep we're set
the hostiles inbound your location
why are they doing this
I got you
have you come
stow down
let me go
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
everything you saw in this walkthrough
was made possible thanks to one thing
experienced seven years ago we started
wildlands with a team of 30 we now have
more than a thousand developers focused
on Ghost Recon in the past two years
alone we've released 19 title updates
breakpoint is bigger and better than
anything we've done before this new game
puts you in the boots of an elite
Special Operations soldier and on a
roller you'll need every bit of your
training and experience to survive the
terrain has a real impact on your
gameplay it can be your enemy oh you're
alive you'll have to cross bodies of
water and climate slopes will make you
slide and temple but you'll have the
agility and new skills with the prone
camo feature you can truly blend into
your environment using your surroundings
to escape or surprise your enemies and
to make the experience more immersive
and intense players can also suffer
serious injuries
depending on the gravity of the world
traders will need to adapt and they
still gave their rifle can there were an
escape unfortunately you will also be
able to heal yourself either on the spot
or in the brand-new bivouac the bivouac
feature will allow players to rest and
refit in the wilderness with their squad
and do what real Special Operations
soldiers do you'll have a wide variety
of tools at your disposal be able to cut
through fences and love to drone that
will allow you to sync shot several
targets even in solo or use a rocket
launcher to take down enemies
but survival isn't only about fighting
it's also about stealth you can pick up
and hide the body of an enemy to remain
undetected or move your fellow wounded
ghosts to safety finally you'll be able
to play as multiple classes and will be
able to change class at any time from
the big work for different classes will
be available at lounge with more to come
the thinking behind many of these
gameplay mechanics came from you our
community let's hear about how Ghost
Recon breakpoint has been inspired by
your feedback you have been our secret
weapon in taking Ghost Recon to a whole
new level
first Ghost Recon breakpoint will
feature a new main story with hundreds
of cutscenes dialogue choices and more
characters for you to discover the
variety of enemies your face will keep
things interesting to say the least
there are many enemy archetypes with
different abilities and weapons and
they're dangerous like this armored
behemoth that will take strength and
precision to take down enemy behavior
has also evolved if you get spotted or
if they become suspicious your enemies
on our coordinate together to take you
want enemies will now always be on
patrol throughout the world a constant
reminder that in Ghost Recon breakpoint
you're the prey and to take them on
you'll now have fan favorites and all
new weapons at your disposal the
gunsmith will give you access to a ton
of different attachments that'll have a
lot more impact on weapon statistics and
performance and you'll have even more
options for character customization and
yes this does include blaust boots
you'll be able to explore a rower
on road and off by air and by sea and
there'll be more military vehicles to
traverse this new world want to go fast
take a falcon
wanna plow through the jungle take a Fat
Boy want to fight the wolves try a
locust
of course Ghost Recon breakpoint is
fully playable in solo and up to four
player co-op and we are happy to
announce that PvP will be available at
launch for all players but that's not
all you'll achieve the same character
throughout your whole experience in
breakpoint this means you keep the same
customization the same skills the same
weapons the same progression across the
entire game and this is just the
beginning every four months after launch
will release a new major expansion
episode to the game that'll include the
very first raid in a Ghost Recon game
here's a taste of what's to come
a lot of people put tons of passion into
the making of this game we could not
have done it without you
our community and so it is our pleasure
to present to you our world premiere our
announce trailer for Ghost Recon
breakpoint
[Music]
I am a ghost Annelise soldier
to strike my enemies before they do
exist
I survived
overcoming any obstacle
[Music]
never surrender him
and with my brothers and sisters at my
side there is no light we fear
[Applause]
you're afraid of death
so would you take the life of my
brothers
[Music]
it doesn't matter how
I
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a ghost do I would expect nothing
less
[Music]
Ghost Recon breakpoint is here it's a
strap on your boots because you have a
mission stay tuned to hear more live
from our studio